oh look I'm crushing Stephanie's head
and crushing Stephanie's head this is
the 3d part you will
hi everyone this is seeing us today we
have two special guests to help us to
prepare this dish come on he's the chef
as you can see he's all prepared dressed
up and have stephanie's here a couple
month ago of Daniel Hernandez you
requested could you make a Peruvian dish
I don't even know how to read it I was
well there you go but I'm mr. gonna read
person dish so I asked a mod if he wants
to be in the video with me to make a
person dip so here we go yay I'm very
happy to be here with the chef Nina and
we're gonna make some giant meatballs
giant Persian books let's call Coupe de
Kock easy which tabriz is a city in
north of northern part of the country
and people over there really love it and
they make it all the time my dad is
actually from a region around there and
he definitely loves this one either just
this particular this very much it's not
something that you can find in every
person's restaurant usually they make it
in households and likely need
traditional places but nonetheless it's
one of the best and those tastylicious
so you're gonna like it are we ready yes
the main and the most important
ingredient is a high up vegetable that
we call garden savory or summer savory
so I have to drive version it over here
because I couldn't on the fresh ones
this is let's go with 2 tablespoons you
hold the spoon of poor it or there are
mixing things would be needs the cooked
things
and the rice and then everything else
come back so we're just going for
cooking this halfway through not all the
way this is yellows with these it's very
important to get the yellow ones so what
we need is one full cup of cooked
trapeze this doubles in size when you
cook it so what we do just take half
first you want to get a big plate so
these always have little stones in it so
what you do you just put it in here and
just take that in perfect ones out it's
not a song but an imperfect one as well
as it's done so this just gives you some
way of you know looking at every single
one of these really quick some people
don't yeah so here's the square a little
water and then emptied uh and then put
some water back in how much water so we
want to have about one inch of water
standing on top of it is this an inch
this is a little less than that's like
saying yeah all right so it should be
actually add a little bit of salt for a
bit and next line we want to cook the
rice what we need is a little over half
a cup of cooked breasts so we're going
to use this rice cooker
right half a cup of rice here in three
times in the water ah 32 times water
over that or three times do you want
something how much how much I'm aside to
the checkout beat the meat gets more
massages an idea I tried to remember
last night but when I am I totally fun
about it we have to make to hard boil
eggs
they suppose part one is new cilantro
this is we're gonna force-feed her [ __ ]
oh my god but it's okay as long as we on
the garden for the summer savory I love
cilantro the key thing is you have to
read the label yeah so what we want is
altogether we want about two-thirds of
the cup of vegetables so here we have
some Bartman savory danielfernandez for
making this for you chicken with
breakfast for week so if you have a
request that you want you to make next
leave it in the comments below and we'll
do something totally different but we'll
give you a shout out of the video we're
getting to shred this that's what shred
the onion so what we do just cut the tip
of it and this game he's just a little
complex yeah so how don't pop that one
don't have this part in for the play
because when we shred it we use that as
a handle so you have to keep the bottom
we can peel the skin and coat
you're going to use the smaller section
the section with smaller holes a little
more arm strength this is my workout for
today ten-minute up the knife is ready
look at the speed difference man holy
cow what you'd really need to do is to
get rid of the juice so just hold it
with your hand and just let the juice
pour it up ground beef see how are we
doing with the split so we pick one of
them out so I know you crush it it's too
hard to crush this means it's not cooked
too well so this one was too hard so
what we are going to do we're gonna just
swirl it a little bit and let it simmer
for a little we just want to speed the
process up so we can put a lid on this
so before mixing this so we still need
to advise let's see how the right now
this one looks actually awkward so this
is good
it's really soft and just really is good
yeah we can turn it off and add it to
the bowl the two really cool tablespoons
good why don't have it to marry the
stuff and pepper will be toothpaste
chick pea flowers as well so let's go
with 2 tablespoons so go generous very
important to mix it really well it has
to come to a really nice taste this
seems to be ready so it's nice and soft
and you can easily crush on so what we
need to do with this is to take one full
cup off this and crush it with the
Persian crusher yes that's the official
name that is officially call this bush
coupe which means unique crusher cool
huh goosh coupe cook this meat crusher
so yeah Nina struggling she's handing
out to Stephanie it's so it looks good
actually right now I like the printing
pressure so depending on how big a pan
is you put the oil according to to cover
to cover all the bottom of it and just
to cook 2 full tablespoons of tomato
paste ya know this is a big fan so
that's grown in half not one
oh this is more about shoot better yes
so 100 it's warm you could add the
tomato paste go to generous just lay it
around to get fried shimmy while doing
the actually shim is an important for
the Persian dance that goes well show me
in the perfect like the spoon prank you
move the school baby so we're doing is
only for text because when it's fried it
gives a little bit of flavor as soon as
just bubbles for like one or two minutes
then we can start adding water so what
you want to do is to add enough water
over half of your meatballs are going to
be floating in the water for a bit
okay let me do it I could do that good
put the heat up unto thee the suit the
water is boiled it's boiled and then
turn down the heat
Toby likes that snapping the wine is
starting to boil what we're going to do
is to peel the shell the eggs crush the
walls no watching with the first you can
do it with the Persian crusher so this
much just break it into small pieces
like as big as that's good
any two eggs to go in there it's gonna
come out to six to eight meatballs you
want to cut eight pieces everything is
ready now we have the moment that we've
all been waiting for here what we have
is the berries the fried onion and the
walnuts and these all are going to go
inside the meatballs so are we ready for
this first of all you have to make sure
your hands are washed so we got the
water running a little bit so that we
can if needs be we can have some water
on our hand to avoid having the nipples
getting stuff use our fingers so you
want to get as big as of that the medium
size limit in your hand like this just
make a little hump hole inside now the
first thing that goes in is the egg then
we put the walnuts dried onion and the
most important part burger
that's one of those importance which
kind of like a signature taste so we got
to close it from one side and then turn
it around close it from the other side
so you might touch the boiling water for
a fraction of a second that's that's the
price you pay oh it's gonna explode this
maybe you can get without ever done so
what I do oh good
wait for one side to cook which takes
about 10 minutes and then we flip it
around after doing this flipping we just
wait for the sport we do and then we'll
have a little bit of sauce at the bottom
and that's when you're done we have
fogged up the house but the sauce is
really thick and nice so when you pour
it on top of the meatball you'll see
stays up there and that means this is
thick and nice the next one it's mine oh
crap honest Stephanie's that's what we
heard you know that I'll go on our mind
so we do eat this with bread but I
personally like to just eat right like
this no prep we go with a little bit of
sauce on top how do i do it i put one
leaf and each song a little bit of
almond you at the top and a little bit
of this coming out yes go straight down
why just to see to show them alone
that's really yeah so when you put it in
from a good guesser as soon as I cut it
is it no what is surprised oh nice big
pitcher different it's really good and I
hope you guys enjoyed the video please
leave your requests below our title
for you believe the way I do it is I put
my thought on and I put my fingers like
this the middle one is comfy like close
this and I pull the index finger out so
that i can use it to snap so with my
phone pushing down with this I'm
trusting and with this unholy as soon as
I lift this little before work this is
gonna hit the little it's just a persian
thing or no mods or anything yeah this
is gonna be on a mod CB yeah Oh everyone
this is mina day we're gonna a kids
today we have a special guest mas gonna
do that again you can't be laughing in
the middle okay he requested